willkommen meine Damen und Herren zu
Phönix Vorort an diesem Sonntagmittag 15
Oktober
2023 eine Woche nach dem Terrorangriff
der heramas auf Israel sind die
Vorbereitungen für eine Gegenoffensive
der Israelis im Gazastreifen so gut wie
abgeschlossen dennoch verschiebt die
Armee den Beginn so zumindest meldet es
die New York Times Grund sei das
schlechte Wetter seit Freitag ist die
Bevölkerung des Gazastreifens des
Nordens dort aufgerufen sich selbst zu
evakuieren international gibt es daran
Kritik und an der Abriegelung des
Gazastreifens geschätzt etwa eine
Million Menschen sind dann auf der
Flucht oder sind zumindest dazu
aufgerufen etwa 700.000 befinden sich
bereits auf dem Weg beide Seiten feuern
weiter Raketen bzw fliegen Luftangriffe
auch durch die Nacht und den Tag über
die Lage der Geiseln gibt es durchaus
unterschiedliche Angaben und wenig
Bestätigung dazu unterdessen aber und
das ist wichtig für alle die deutsche
Staatsangehörige sind hat sich auch die
Bundeswehr eingeschaltet in die
rückkehraktion und fliegt Notizen aus
Israel und dem
Gazastreifen der Raketenbeschuss der
Hamas auf Israel geht auch in der
vergangenen Nacht weiter Ziel Tel Aviv
und das Zentrum des Landes die meisten
Angriffe werden vom abfangsystem
irondome abgewehrt die is Luftwaffe
ihrerseits greift nach eigenen Angaben
weiter hamasziele im Gazastreifen an
darunter auch unterirdische Tunnel und
Wohnsitze hochrangiger
Terroristen wir fordern erneut alle
Bewohner im Norden von Gaza auf begebt
euch in den
Süden hört auf unsere wahnung es wird
dort größere militärische Aktionen geben
also bringt euch bitte in
Sicherheit die Armee kündigt heute
erneut ein Zeitfenster für die
Evakuierung von Zivilisten aus dem
Norden des Gazastreifens an das Militär
werde in diesem Zeitraum den Korridor
nicht angreifen 10tausende Menschen sind
bereits Richtung Süden geflohen wir
wollen die Dinge etwas genauer
hinterfragen deswegen bin ich jetzt in
Tel Aviv verbunden mit ARD Korrespondent
kilan Neuwert Herr Neuwert lassen Sie
uns zunächst reden über die
angekündigte Gegenoffensive
Bodenoffensive im Gaza Streifen die New
York Times meldet eine Verzögerung
obwohl es bisher ja kein echtes Datum
dafür gab was weiß man bei Ihnen über
diese
Situation ja sie haben es angesprochen
im Moment ist das alles so möchte ich
das Betonen noch sehr viel
Kaffeesatzleserei denn was können wir
über eine offensive sagen von der wir
nichts Näheres wissen ich halte es also
für sehr früh auch um hier von
Verzögerungen zu sprechen fakt ist
Israel hat in den letzten Tagen rund um
den Gazastreifen seine Truppen massiert
dort Artillerie Kampfpanzer
kampfunterstützungstruppen
zusammengezogen und befindet sich so se
nennt das die Armee auch offiziell in
einer Vorbereitungsphase fakt ist auch
dass die Armee erklärt hat dass man Gaza
dass man die Hamas Ziele im Gazastreifen
zu Land zu Luft und zu Wasser angreifen
wird aber im Moment so hören wir
offiziell sei noch nicht entschieden wie
in welcher Form und wann wir halten also
fest wir sind in einer Phase der
Vorbereitung immer noch mehr lässt sich
dazu seriös im Moment nicht sagen mhm
und sagen wir mal zu den grundsätzlichen
Bedingungen einer Bodenoffensive noch
einmal nachgefragt das ist gerade
gegenüber der Hamas die ja mehr oder
weniger gerill Taktik haben doch
schwierig und vor allen Dingen auch ihre
Rückzugsgebiete in Hochhäusern und in
Tunneln wie will man damit
umgehen so ist es die Hamas verfügt
soweit wir wissen im gaserstreifen über
ein sehr weit verzweigtes System an
Tunneln das sind Tunnel ganz
verschiedener Natur manche davon dienen
als Rückzugsräume als Schutzräume an
andere dienen dafür um dort Vorräte
vorzuhalten wieder andere dienen dafür
um von dort aus Angriffe zu starten oder
um sich auch unterhalb des Gazastreifens
zu bewegen wenn wir jetzt auf diese
Bodenoffensive diese mögliche diese
eventuell bevorstehende blicken dann
reden wir im Kern darüber dass es sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass die israelische
Armee Angriffe zunächst im Norden des
Landes starten wird warum weil sie dort
auch die Zivilbevölkerung aufgefordert
hat sich auf den Weg in den Süden zu
begeben ich möchte ihn gerne aus meinen
Erinnerung an eben diesen Norden des
Gazastreifens in friedlicheren Zeiten
berichten damit sie ein Bild haben wie
es dort in etwa aussieht der Norden wird
dominiert von gazastadt eine Großstadt
größtenteils geprägt von mehrstöckigen
Gebäuden Hochhäusern dazwischen auch
kleinere Häuser immer mal wieder engere
Straßen zumteils aber auch weitere
Straßen Plätze also urbane Infrastruktur
Militärs sprechen in solchem Gelände
gerne vom dreidimensionalen Kampf vom
Häuserkampf weil hier eine potenzielle
Bedrohung aus jeder Richtung kommen kann
ein Schütze kann das Feuer aus dem
Fenster eines Hauses eröffnen er kann
auf der Straße auftauchen er kann hinter
oder möglicherweise unter Soldaten
auftauchen und Israel muss sich in einer
solchen Situation wenn es zu einer
Bodenoffensive kommen sollte darauf
einstellen dass es eine sehr viel
größere Zahl an Toten und Verwundeten
gibt eine größere Zahl an Toten und
Verwundeten Soldaten gibt als die die
wir im Moment haben oder als die die man
auch in den letzten Jahren entlang der
Grenze zu Gaza gesehen hat und definitiv
braucht man für die Art Kampfhandlung so
wie sie das beschrieben haben eine
Unterstützung aus der Luft das ist das
was im Moment in Abrede gestellt ist
aufgrund der Wetterlage das lassen wir
mal dahinestellt reden wir über die
Geiseln das ist die Frage die sich sehr
sehr viele Menschen stellen und wo es
keine richtig stabilen Zahlen gibt
welche kennen sie wir kennen eine Zahl
von 126 Geiseln von Zivilisten die in
den gaserstreifen verschleppt worden
sein sollen im Schwerpunkt wohl am
vergangenen Samstag als es diesen
Überfall gab von militanten
Palästinensern die eingedrungen sind
nach Israel in kibuze also in kleine
Orte in der Nähe des gasastreifens
beispielsweise und die Menschen von dort
regelrecht verschleppt haben und ich
möchte fast sagen ich betone das es mein
Eindruck von hier vorort dass Israel
aufgrund dieser Geiselnahmen eine Art
kollektives Trauma erlebt das Land zeigt
sich jetzt vereint im Schmerz weil es so
etwas einfach nicht gegeben hat gestern
haben sich hier in Tel Aviv an Plätzen
an denen wir noch vor wenigen Wochen
hunderttausende gesehen haben die gegen
die Regierung demonstriert haben
Menschen versammelt wenn auch nur einige
hundert die Kerzen angezündet haben die
gebetet haben aufgrund dieser Situation
die Bilder von vermissten an Wände
geklebt haben um damit das sehr sehr
deutliche Signal zu denken zu senden
dass man wütend ist dass man traurig ist
dass man entsetzt ist und das ist eine
Situation in der Israel so mein Eindruck
enger näher zusammenrückt in der die
Spaltung der Gesellschaft die wir
zuletzt da erlebt haben zumindest ein
Stück weit aufgehoben ist Neuwert noch
eine Schlussfrage ähm viele ähm
insbesondere mit deutschen Wurzeln
wollten in den letzten Tagen das Land
verlassen viele Nationen haben sehr
schnell ausgeflogen bei den Deutschen
hat das alles eine gewisse
anlaufschwierigkeit gehabt haben Sie
einen Überblick darüber wie aktuell die
Rückholaktion läuft und wie viele
Deutsche jetzt noch da sind die das Land
verlassen möchten also was ich Ihnen
sagen kann ist dass die Rückholaktion
läuft es ist auch wieder angekündigt
dass die deutsche Luftwaffe deutsche
ausfliegen und außer Lande bringen wird
wie viele Deutsche tatsächlich noch hier
sind ich spreche jetzt hier in erster
Linie von Touristen darüber kann ich im
Moment nur mutmaßen was wir wissen ist
dass nach den letzten Zahlen des
Auswärtigen Amtes etwa 2800 Menschen
außer Landes gebracht worden sind es
kursieren ja auch Zahlen wie viele auf
dieser ausreiseliste des Auswärtigen
Amtes stehen diese Zahlen so meine
Einschätzung sind aber eher mit Vorsicht
zu betrachten denn aus diesen Listen
muss man sich auch selbst wieder
austragen wenn das nicht passiert iert
steht man theoretischerweise noch da
drauf und wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen in dieser Situation dass es
natürlich Menschen gibt die auf dieser
Liste stehen mich eingeschlossen die
zunächst Vorhaben hier vor Ort zu
verbleiben das gilt für viele meiner
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das gilt
natürlich auch für diplomatisches
Personal deutsches diplomatisches
Personal hier vor Ort die erstmal hier
verbleiben werden um ihren Job zu machen
solange bis die Lage möglicherweise
unkalkulierbar wird weil wir eine
größere Eskalation im Norden erleben mhm
und das ist gut dass sie ihren Job vor
Ort machen wir bedanken uns für Ihre
Zeit passen Sie auf sich auf das war ed
Korrespondent kilan Neuwert für uns
geschaltet aus Tel Aviv
merci meine Damen und Herren das war die
Perspektive von vor Ort natürlich gibt
es auch die politische Perspektive die
wir hier in Deutschland abholen können
der Deutsche Bundestag hat in dieser
Woche ein starkes Zeichen gesetzt mit
einer gemeinsamen Erklärung und mit
einem Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages
kann ich jetzt sprechen in Berlin im ARD
Hauptstadtstudio steht ST für uns der
Bundestagsabgeordnete ruderich
Kiesewetter Mitglied der CDU CSU
Bundestagsfraktion Mitglied im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss und Oberst ad ich
grüße sie in die Hauptstadt her
giesewetter ich grüße Sie Frau Arland
guten Tag
lassen Sie uns bei der Lage in Israel
beginnen wie schätzen sie mit ihrem ganz
besonderen militärischen Hintergrund die
aktuelle Lage und vor allen Dingen auch
das hin und her um diese Vorbereitung
einer Gegenoffensive
ein
nun Israel ist angegriffen worden wie in
ihrer Geschichte nur sehr selten vor 50
Jahren Jon kipur Krieg 6ch Tage Krieg 67
das eine Ausnahmesituation für das Land
und zugleich durch die internationale
Medienpräsenz durch den Druck den
gewisse Regionen auch ausüben ist Israel
aufgerufen natürlich mit aller Härte die
Hamas zu zerschlagen und das müssen sie
bedachtsam machen weil natürlich es auch
um die Frage der Bilder geht und hierbei
bereitet sich Israel einerseits vor den
Gazastreifen nicht nur abzuriegeln
sondern dort auch sehr konsequent die
Hammers zu zerschlagen aber es droht auf
der anderen Seite ein meerfrontenkrieg
weil natürlich dieser furchtbare Angriff
eine sagen wir mal sehr sorgfältig
geplante Operation ist die natürlich
auch Russland in die Hände arbeitet weil
die Aufmerksamkeit von der Ukraine
abgezogen wird und auch dem Iran der im
Hintergrund und die Strippen gezogen hat
und Hamas zusammen mit Hisbollah im
Libanon unterstützt hat beim Aufbau
eines Büros also hier müssen wir auch
auf die großen Linien achten und Israel
wird mit aller Härte vorgehen müssen
aber das muss vorbereitet sein auch um
noch schrecklichere Bilder zu vermeiden
die ja schon die Hamas provoziert haben
ja sie haben Herr kwetter die Lage der
Zivilisten jetzt durchaus schon mit
inkludiert in das was Sie beschrieben
haben und die Frage und die Macht Macht
der Bilder eben ebenso mit diesem
speziellen Hintergrund den sie haben
diesen militärischen
Hintergrund Zivilisten und Kampfhandlung
das ist eine komplizierte
Gemengelage ist dieses Dilemma vor dem
man da steht überhaupt irgendwie
auflösbar völkerrechtlich ist Israel
völlig befugt hier gegen die Hamas
vorzugehen deswegen ja auch der Aufruf
an die Zivilbevölkerung gasas sich in
den Süden zu begeben und der Zeitraum
der jetzt noch Wonnen wird in der
Vorbereitung auf der anderen Seite muss
Israel natürlich schauen dass sie sich
so vorbereiten dass die eigenen Opfer
möglichst gering sind jedenfalls hat
Israel die innenpolitische Spaltung
überwunden die netanahu verursacht hat
jetzt geht es aber darum dass wir an der
Seite Israel stehen und alles tun dass
Israel in der Lage ist die Hamas restlos
zu beseitigen wir müssen so klar
sprechen hier gibt es nur schwarz oder
weiß denn wenn die Hamas einen Erfolg
davon trägt dann wird der Terror der
Hamas weiter fortgesetzt werden parallel
wirken natürlich die Verhandlungen mit
Ägypten im Hintergrund mit Saudi-Arabien
wo Israel intensiv auch mit
internationaler Unterstützung beteiligt
ist aber hier gilt beides Diplomatie und
Härte und die Härte muss Israel zeigen
weil sonst Hamas sich bestärkt fühlt
auch andere Terrororganisationen sich
bestärkt fühlen bevor wir vielleicht
gleich noch mal auf die ganz große Linie
kommen Wetter das menschliche ist ein
wichtiger Faktor auch in Gesprächen wie
wir es jetzt führen Stichwort deutsche
Staatsbürger
äh die Rückholaktion die rückkehraktion
von manchen durchaus als ein Fiasko äh
deklariert ich nehme den Begriff
Afghanistan jetzt bewusst nicht in den
Mund aber
für manche die vor Ort stundenlang in
einer Hotline waren hatte der Begriff
Auswärtiges Amt tatsächlich noch mal mit
Betonung auf der zweiten Wortsilbe noch
ein ganz anderen Begriff
wovon hängt es eigentlich ab das was wir
heute Nacht erlebt haben dass sich dann
die Luftwaffe die Bundeswehr in diesen
Prozess mit Einschalten darf
nun das ist durch die sehr schwierige
Haltung der lufthanser in manchen
Bereichen und der mangelde Druck des
Auswärtigen Amtes sicherlich erklärbar
allerdings fehlt uns hier eine
strategische Kultur generell uns darauf
einzustellen wenn solche Krisenlagen
sind sofort eventualplungen zu ziehen
und sofort zu prüfen wo die Streitkräfte
verfügbar sind wo vielleicht
eingemottete A380 bereit gehalten werden
könnten also tatsächlich mit Geld und
Aufwand abrufbar sind wo bestimmte
andere von Europa finanzierte
lufttransportfähigkeiten vorgehalten
werden uns fehlt schlichtweg die
strategische Kultur die Haltung sofort
zu reagieren wir sehen es auch daran als
wir im auswerärtigen Ausschuss über
evakuierungsflüge nachfragten wurde uns
gesagt es handelt sich nicht um
Evakuierung sondern um erweiterte
kommerzielle Flüge wir dürfen ja keine
Schere im Kopf haben wir dürfen nicht
schön reden das muss sauber
nachgearbeitet werden wir vom Parlament
auch wir von der Union sind bereit das v
voll und ganz zu unterstützen es geht um
die Wehrhaftigkeit unseres Landes und
dass unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger unser
Vertrauen in unser Land haben und ich
selber habe es sehr intensiv mitbekommen
mit Schulklassen aus Baden-Württemberg
die sich hängen gelassen gefühlt haben
die Diplomatie hat sich zwar gekümmert
aber zu wenig zu spät wir brauchen hier
eine andere Kultur und einen besseren
Umgang mit solchen Fragen ja Herr
Kiesewetter in den letzten Tagen ist der
Begriff der staatsraon ganz häufig
bemüht würden auch im Deutschen
Bundestag mit dieser einmütigen
gemeinsamen Erklärung die Frage die sich
manch im Nachgang stellen bleibt das
hier bei guten Worten oder wo endet das
ganz
konkret ich bin Ihnen sehr dankbar für
diesen Punkt den als Kanzlerin Merkel
dies im März 2008 vor der Knesset sagte
fügte sie hinzu und in einer Stunde der
Bewährung dürfen es keine leeren Worte
sein wir müssen aufpassen dass wir nicht
nur leere Worte liefern sondern Israel
auch bei uns innen politisch
unterstützen jüdische Einrichtungen
schützen und allen Organisationen die
hier versuchen zu relativieren die
ganzen Menschen die jetzt sagen ja aber
müssen besser aufgeklärt werden ich
spreche hier auch unser Bildungssystem
an ich spreche hier auch
Schwerpunktschulen in Neuköln und in
anderen Teilen Deutschlands an es ist
nicht hinnehmbar dass wir im Rahmen der
Toleranz der Intoleranz gegenüber Israel
Freiräume geben das zerstört die
Toleranz und stört vor allen Dingen die
Wehrhaftigkeit unseres Landes wir müssen
hier sehr klar sagen Staatsraison heißt
das Existenzrecht Israels ist in Gefahr
im übrigen ist auch das Existenzrecht
der Ukraine in Gefahr wir brauchen eine
andere Kultur im Umgang mit Partnern die
engstens mit uns verbunden sind und bei
Israel haben wir die besondere
historische Verantwortung dazu gehört
auch das Angebot dass die Luftwaffe show
of force zeigt dass wir aus unifel
vielleicht das eine oder andere Schiff
heraus lösen und mit Israel gemeinsam
patroulieren lassen es geht darum mehr
als nur Lippenbekenntnisse zu machen
sondern ganz praktisch mit dem was
verfügbar ist zu zeigen dass wir
unverbrüchlich an der Seite Israels
stehen nur dann haben wir auch
politischen Einfluss in der Region
vielen Dank für ihre Position für ihre
Einordnung über Akzente künftig in der
deutschen Außenpolitik werden wir ein
nächstes Mal noch ein bisschen genauer
reden Stichwort Richtung Iran und Qatar
ganz herzlichen Dank für die
Erkenntnisse heute Mittag Roderich
kiesew da liegen die eigentlichen
Verursacher ja ruderich Kiesewetter war
das hier bei Phönix CDU
Bundestagsabgeordneter Oberst ad und
Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss ich
danke Ihnen und Grüße nach Berlin
mer herzlichen
Dank meine Damen und Herren wir wollen
vor Ort noch einige Positionen aufnehmen
vor Ort das heißt in Israel in diesem
Falle ganz konkret in Tel Aviv tagt
natürlich in St in diesen Stunden nicht
nur ständig das Kabinett und die
Ministerien sind auf Hochtouren sondern
auch der nationale Sicherheitsrat der
Israelis der in diesen Stunden besonders
gefordert ist die gesprächsfäden auch in
alle Richtungen zusammenzuhalten an
diesem Vormittag hat sich geäußert Sari
haknebi er ist Leiter des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates guten Abend ich werde
heute auch Ihnen alle berichten und ich
hoffe dass es eine Art von jix sein wird
zwischen uns
über die verschiedene Bewegungen die wir
machen gerade im Krieg über unsere
Entscheidungen politische
entscheidungminister
Verteidigungsminister und so weiter oder
im Kabinett wir treffen alle
Entscheidungen zusammen aber natürlich
mit außenkörperschaften wie z.B der
mosat und inneren Geheimdienst und so
weiter ich werde berichten über die
Richtungen des Krieges was unsere Ziele
sind
etc wir wollen hier durch dieses Treffen
hier auch mehr Information geben also
der Öffentlichkeit und es gibt viele
Fragen die noch zu beantworten sind und
man erwartet auch ein Sieg aber ich
werde ein paar Mal persönliche Wörte ein
paar persönliche Worte sagen wir sen
eine sehr starke
Nation und ich kenne das von zu Hause
ich bin in einem Haus
aufgewachsen wo ich diese Sachen erkannt
habe dass sogar nach 2000 Jahren von
Diaspora haben wir alles geschafft nach
den
Progromen nach die Vernichtungsaktionen
gegen uns und haben wir sogar unsere
Unabhängigkeit bekommen ich habe meine
Eltern gelernt sie haben gegen die
brittenen damals gekämpft
als
untergrundsorganisation und ohne
Offizier rekutiert zu werden sie gar
keine sie hatten in dem
Sinne alles direkt gemacht also die
Judenstadt hat jetzt einen Riesenschlag
bekommen am
freus von Familien sind heute gebrochen
sie
weinen tiefen Kummer und Sorge und
Schmerz ich kenne das wie das
aussieht
und auch in meinem Büro selbst in
Ball meine Sekretärin also ist eine
junge
Soldatin hat ihr Partner verloren er
heißt ad Oder hieß Adi und in diesem
bösen
Sabbat aber ich glaube und ich WE ist
dass auch dieses Mal werden wir da all
das tun was wir tun
müssen
und das ist etwas
was also eine Frage zwei Fragen
eigentlich die erste Frage die ich
möchte etwas vorlesen was Sie gesagt
haben se Tagen vor
diesemeg haben sie w gesagt zwei Jahre
die Hamas nicht unternommen nicht
angeschossen ist gezügelt die Hamas ist
se gezügelt und Hamas
ist abgeschreckt für die nächsten 15
Jahren ja was sagen Sie dazu das ist ein
Fehler mein
Fehler und dieser Fehler
reflektiert den Fehler von allen über
viele Jahren
oder gerade in letzten Zeit unser Fehler
und wir haben daran geglaubt dass die
Hamas die Konsequenzen gezogen hast was
im letzten Krieg passiert ist haben sie
mit ägyptistischen
Nachrichten äh Dienste gesprochen und
Information bekommen die Antwort ist
nein sie haben uns nicht gesagt das
heißt die Ägypter haben uns oder
wendeten an uns nicht haben zu uns nicht
direkt oder indirekt etwas gesagt also
nicht durch zwingendes Auges oder
indirekt mit Flüstern nein nie passiert
und wir hatten gar keine Kontakt ehrlich
gesagt mit
ihnen und auch Leute die z.B manchmal in
Kontakt mit ihnen manchmal stehen wir
haben von ihnen nichts
gehört es ist fake News und es wurde
natürlich
dementiert schman von
Channel also der stat israel hat versagt
komplett muss man auch sagen
leider hat eine indirekte Verantwort
übernommen und
wir haben SAS von Ministerpräsident
nicht gehört oder auch von Ihnen oder
Verantwort zu
übernehmen ich bin der Meinung dass der
OB Recht hat das ist eine ganz klare
wertvolle Aussage und er hat eigentlich
gesagt wir haben die Mission nicht
erfüllt und das wissen wir auch ja alle
ja so ist es der ST israel hat versagt
in dem
Sinne
wirprüft geprüft jetzt ehrlich gesagt
von alle entsprechend Körperschaften die
es prüfen
müssen aber das wird noch kommen eine
große Untersuchung selbstverständlich
das wird das kommt auf uns zu auf un zu
und das ist sehr wichtig dass es
schicksalhaft ist in J
Nacht also zweieinhalb Stunden bevor das
ganze angefangen hat es gab Indikationen
dass etwas unregelmäßiges passiert und
inl gehimft wurde gerade
gerufen zu seinem Stab und er hat auch
mit den Armeechefs gesprochen und sie
dachten anhand der Evidenz was sie
hatten dass es nicht so schlimm ist und
natürlich alles wird geklärt sein in der
Zukunft sogar deren hat auch ein paar
eigene Soldaten D hingeschickt die sind
fast alle
gefallen
und wir
salutieren für ihre Arbeit was sie
gemacht haben aber alles wird geprüft
das kann nicht versprechen
ähm es wird nichts so bleiben wie das
war und nach diesen ruhigen und
gelassenen Worten des nationalen
Sicherheitsberaters in Israel gehen wir
zu einer fundierten Einschätzung nach
Aschaffenburg und ich freue mich dass
sich wieder Zeit nimmt für uns Professor
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler
Universität Köln Grüße sie am Mittag
nach archaffenburg Professor Jäger grüß
sie Frau Ahland
ähm beginnen wir noch einmal bei der
Bewertung dieses so unglaublichen
Vorganges der ja mit 9-1even auch eine
Kennzeichnung gefunden hat ein 9/11 für
Israel eine Woche danach und mit ein
bisschen Abstand zu diesen Geschehnissen
des letzten Wochenendes stehen wir
möglicherweise vor einem Flächenbrand
und was müsste passieren damit es nicht
so kommt ich würde gern den Begriff des
von 9/eleven noch mal aufgreifen denn
das ist ja gleichgesetzt worden und das
mag man hinsichtlich der Zahl der Opfer
das Schocks in der Gesellschaft zu sehen
aber eigentlich ist das was Israel
erlebt hat schlimmer als 9/1even denn es
hat damals 2001 niemand vorhergesehen
dass Flugzeuge ins World Trade Center
fliegen das war sozusagen außerhalb des
Vorstellungsvermögens das was Israel
erlebt hat ist nicht außerhalb
Vorstellungsvermögens gewesen sondern
man wusste dass die Grenze unsicher ist
man hat sie auf unterschiedliche Weise
gesichert die die Hamas jeweils
überwunden hat und die Hamas käp
Terroristen waren ausgesprochen gut
informiert welche Wege sie wählen müssen
wen sie wo finden wen sie wo töten
können
äh und das ist etwas was in der in den
Diensten Israels aufgearbeitet werden
muss und zwar jetzt mit Hochdruck und
hinsichtlich der Frage ob man denn jetzt
über die intelligence verfügt
ausreichend Informationen zu haben dass
man begründete Entscheidungen treffen
kann und dann sind wir mittendrin in der
Frage die sie anschlossen nämlich äh was
geschieht momentan hinsichtlich der
bodenoperation die angekündigt wurde für
Gaza welche Wirkungen wird sie haben
wird sie die hisbolla mit auf den Plan
rufen und möglicherweise einen Krieg aus
Libanon gegen Israel äh beginnen lassen
welche Position wird Iran dabei
einnehmen das heißt die Dienste arbeiten
hier jetzt an dieser Frage und auf einer
anderen Ebene sind die Diplomaten
unterwegs um herauszubekommen welche
Position welche Staaten einnehmen und
die nicht nur der Abschreckung dienen
die nicht nur Worte sind sondern wo man
dann taten äh äh vermuten kann und das
ist eine derart unsichere Lage dass äh
die israelische Regierung jetzt wirklich
vor einer ganz schwierigen Entscheidung
steht wie sie ihr Ziel die Hamas zu
zerschlagen und ein Ziel an dem sie
festhalten wird äh letztlich umsetzt ja
sie haben es angesprochen Professor
Jäger die drohgeberärden sind bereits da
gleichzeitig gibt es jetzt in Israel äh
nicht die Position diese gesprächsfäden
die sie auch schon teilweise beschrieben
haben äh Richtung Saudi Arabien Richtung
Qatar etc ad hoc aufzunehmen wer könnte
diesen Job wenn ich mal so salop sagen
darf jetzt leisten ist es
blinken es gibt momentan zwei Ebenen auf
denen versucht wird Einfluss zu nehmen
auf die Hamas das eine ist sehr konkret
äh wenn es darum geht die Geiseln zu
befreien und in diesem Zusammenhang auch
äh bestimmt die Bürger anderer Staaten
aus Gaza
herauszubkommen humanitäre Hilfe nach
Gaza hinein zu bekommen da sind die
Amerikaner mit beschäftigt das ist
Ägypten mit beschäftigt äh das ist die
eine Ebene und hier ist es schon bisher
nicht möglich eine Lösung zu finden aber
das wäre noch das was man äh lösen
könnte
äh die andere Frage nämlich ist eine
Vermittlung möglich die Israel von dem
Ziel abbringt die Hamas zu zerschlagen
da sehe ich momentan überhaupt keine
Möglichkeit denn Israel ist aufgefordert
und fordert sich selbst auf und die
abstchreckung gegen Hamas
wiederherzustellen äh diese Position es
wird sich keiner trauen uns anzugreifen
jetzt wirklich wieder physisch zu
unterlegen eine Position die wie wir
eben gehört haben ja gerade dazu geführt
hat dass man diese vielen Informationen
die man ausgase hatte falsch
eingeschätzt hat und zu einer falschen
Analyse kam ja und ob ein zweiter
Flugzeugträger der Amerikaner im
östlichen Mittelmeer helfen wird
sozusagen diese Abschreckung zu leisten
wird die Zeit erstmal zeigen ich bedanke
mich für die erste Runde und über diese
strategischen und geopolitischen
Optionen können wir gleich weiter reden
wenn wir uns noch ein bisschen näher
diesem Begriff Gaza annähern und einen
kurzen Beitrag dazu spielen die
Landkarte im Nahen Osten das muss man
vorausschicken ist ja eher eine
politische in vielen Fällen eben keine
gewachsene Struktur Grenzlinien wurden
z.B in hinternzimmern an grünen Tischen
oder eben in Kriegen gezogen und ein
gravierendes Beispiel dafür welche
gewaltsamen Folgen das haben kann ist
der gazaastreifen hier ganz besonders
ein Gebiet das hochexplosiv nennen kann
und zwar jeden Tag eine einige
Eindrücke der Gazastreifen liegt im
Südwesten von Israel an der Grenze zu
Ägypten er ist etwa 10 km breit 40 km
lang und existiert so seit
1949 dem Ende des ersten
arabisch-israelischen Krieges seine
Kontrolle wechselt über die Jahrzehnte
zunächst wird der Gazastreifen von
Ägypten verwaltet 1967 bes Set Israel
ihn 1994 geht die Verwaltung
größtenteils an die Palästinenser über
2005 zieht Israel seine Truppen ab 2007
ergreift die radikalislamische Hamas die
Macht der Gazastreifen ist mit 2,2
Millionen Einwohnern sehr dicht
besiedelt israel hat das Gebiet mit
einem Sperrzaun abgeriegelt es gibt drei
Grenzübergänge zwei nach Israel und
einen nach
Ägypten optisch war sehr schön zu sehen
eine ganz glatte klare Linie Professor
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler
Universität Köln zugeschaltet aus
Aschaffenburg das bringt uns noch einmal
in diese
diskussionslage rund um mögliche
Optionen für den Nahen Osten wer jetzt
mal ganz offen gefragt hat den Plan B
für
Gaza niemand das ist die Antwort die man
nach Jahrzehnten geben muss in denen die
zwei
staatenlösung versucht wurde und auch
diese Einschätzung muss ich schon gleich
wieder einschränken denn in den letzten
Jahren hat man den Begriff zwei
staatenlösung eher als mon monstrants
vor sich
hergetragen sozusagen eine diplomatische
Floskel ohne Inhalt weil keiner wusste
wie das letztlich umgesetzt wird am Ende
aber besteht das große Problem darin
dass islamistische Organisation eben wie
die Hamas eine Entwicklung dieses
Gebietes ver hindern auf diese Art und
Weise wird eben kein Miteinander
entstehen können und das ist die der der
größte Hinderungsgrund für eine
politische Lösung die ja gesucht wurde
in den letzten Jahren indem man die
Isolation Israels nach und nach
aufgebrochen hat arabische Staaten
Israel anerkannt haben diplomatische
Beziehungen aufgenommen haben und auf
diesem Weg wollte man eigentlich
weitergehen Stück für Stück es gab einen
Staat der daran überhaupt kein Interesse
hat der darin in dieser Entwicklung
seine eigene Sicherheit und seine das
Streben nach Vormachtstellung gefährdet
sieht das ist der Iran und Iran steckt
eben auch hinter diesem Angriff von
Hamas der der genau diese Entwicklung
für den Nahen Osten verhindern soll
trotz aller Klarheit wir wagen uns noch
eine zweite Einschätzung und ich
akzeptiere auch wieder ein Ja oder ein
nein der neue Nahe Osten wenn wir das
mal so formulieren wollen Professor
Jäger wie müsste der aussehen um stabil
zu sein wenn wir beide jetzt das
Reisbrett in der Hand hätten es lässt
sich eben am Reißbrett nicht planen Sie
haben ja am Anfang gesagt da sind
Grenzen gezogen worden am reispit das
ist immer schwierig gesellschaftliche
Entwicklungen lassen sich nicht im Labor
untersuchen und das was den Nahen Osten
und den Mittleren Osten die man
zusammenhen muss momentan ausmacht ist
eine starke Rivalität zwischen drei
Mächten nämlich Iran der Türkei und
Saudi-Arabien und auch wenn hier immer
mal wieder der Eindruck entsteht als
könnten die miteinander besteht eben
eine so tiefe Gegnerschaft zwischen
diesen Staaten die jeweils nach der
Vorherrschaft hier Streben und das ist
der eigentliche die eigentliche
Triebfeder für diese ganzen Konflikte
und
dies zu lösen ist aufgrund der
unterschiedlichen politisch religiösen
Orientierungen der unterschiedlichen äh
inneren Verhältnisse aus meiner Sicht ab
nicht möglich ja Professor Jäger wir
gönnen uns noch einen letzten knappen
Punkt von den drei von Ihnen
angesprochenen Mächten hat nur eine den
Finger gehoben wenn es aktuell um
vermittelnde Aktionen geht das war die
Türkei Herr Erdogan bezogen auf die
Geiseln es gibt einen anderen großen
Player auf der Welt der jetzt noch mal
nach vorne getreten ist auch noch mal
mit der Begrifflichkeit zwei
staatenlösung und einer internationalen
Friedenskonferenz nämlich China ist da
viel Wunschdenken drin was was meinen
sie ja das ist äh nicht mal Wunschdenken
sondern das ist sozusagen in die
chinesische Monstranz die immer vor der
Diplomatie herläuft sozusagen zu tun als
könnte man mit allem gut und es müssten
nur alle miteinander reden äh wenn wir
Chinas Verhältnis zu Taiwan anbetrachten
sehen wir dass die chinesische Politik
eigentlich ganz anders ausgestrengt ist
und das was in den vor vor Jahrzehnten
überlegt wurde nämlich so etwas wie eine
KSZE für den mit mitleren Osten zu
organisieren das wäre ja die Umsetzung
dieser chinesischen Idee aber derartiges
geschieht nicht und China selbst hat in
den letzten Jahren dafür gesorgt hier
erheblichen Einfluss zu bekommen durch
Investitionen die USA aus diesem Gebiet
eben auch herauszudrängen was manchmal
gar nicht nötig war weil die USA von
alleine gegangen sind
china hat aber nicht den Einfluss und
ist nicht bereit den mit
genauso viel Risiko in äh den Mittleren
Osten zu gehen wie die Vereinigten
Staaten sie spielen derzeit deswegen nur
am Rand eine Rolle und das versuchen sie
durch solche Reden dann ein wenig
diplomatisch aufzuwerten vielen Dank für
die zweite Runde die chinesische
monstrans nehmen wir mit und ich darf
ergänzen vielleicht für die jüngeren
Jahrgänge die KSZE also die Konferenz
für Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in
Europa die man mit einer Schlussakte
endete in Helsinki damals in Finnland
und äh für manche zumindestens eine
gewisse Wegmarke dargestellt hat danke
für Z wir reden gleich weiter Professor
Jäger und meine Damen und Herren was wir
Ihnen gleich zeigen wollen ist noch
einmal auch ein Ton wir haben darüber
gesprochen die Landkarte die schwierigen
Bedingungen ne wir haben ganz viel über
den gaserreifen gesprochen aber
natürlich auch im Westjordanland in der
Westbank sind
Palästinenser das ist auch ein
kompliziertes System dort in ramala mit
der palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde
auch da Korruption verschiedene Dinge
die nicht funktionieren aber auch da
jetzt ein eine Positionierung und zwar
ganz konkret von dem vertachmitglied
Mustafa baguti das wollen wir ihn noch
zeigen ich denke das palästinensische
Volk erlebte die schlimmste Situation
seit
1988 es besteht das echte Potenzial für
eine weitere
Katastrophe leider hat Israel mit
Unterstützung der USA und Akzeptanz
vieler westlichen
Regierung wieder Maßnahmen und
gefährliche Verfahren gegen die
palästinensische Bevölkerung eingeleitet
erstens werden alle Palästinenser
entmenschlicht nicht nur Hamas zweite
sind Akte kollektiver Bestrafung und
drittens geht es um Akte die zu der
schlimmsten ethnischen Säuberung im 21
Jahrhundert führen und dann schließlich
die Bombardierung die ein echter
Völkermord und der der palästinensischen
Führung in Gaza ist netanu und seine
faschistische Regierung haben die
jüngsten Ereignisse genutzt um ihre
Pläne die sie schon früher hatten
fortzusetzen und leider ist das wir
heute sehen nichts
Neues was wir heute sehen ist eine
Wiederholung
vieleraggression aber in einem nieer
gewesenen Ausmaß und niemand kann uns
überzeugen davon dass das was netanah
und seine Regierung heute machen nur
eine Reaktion ist auf das was die
Palästinenser getan haben nein was heute
passiert wurde vor Jahren schon geplant
um die Palästinenser im Gazastreifen
völlig zu zerstören erster Schritt ist
die
Entmenschlichung der Palästinenser das
Schlimmste was man je sagen konnte war
das was der israelische
Verteidigungsminister galand gesagt
nämlich die Palästinenser menschliche
Tiere Human Rights Watch sagte dass es
eine empörende Erklärung und sagt
gleichzeitig das ist eine Vorbereitung
für die Kriegsverbrechen die Israel
verübt es wurden so viele Lügen
verbreitet wir
erleben die Medien die man nur als
schwarze Medien bezeichnen kann die
viele falsche Informationen verbreiten
auf die Behauptung dass es zu
Vergewaltigung durch die Leute aus gaz
gekommen ist die Los Angeles Times hat
sich dafür entschuldigt so irreführende
Information zu verbreiten hat gesagt
nichts belegt die Behauptung von netanah
und von Israel dass so etwas passiert
sein könnte CNN entschuldigte sich auch
dafür dass man berichtet hatte von
enthupteten Kindern aber eine weitere
Lüge die netan in die Welt gesetzt hat
und von vielen
amerikanischen wiederholt wurde aber
jetzt wurde das als Lüge entlarft und
die dritte dramatische Lüge war dass
Netanyahu künstliche Intelligenz
eingesetzt hat um ein verbrennendes
israelisches Kind zu zeigen und ein
hochgeachteter Journalist Jackson Hinkel
hat selbst darauf hingewiesen dass man
hier künstliche Intelligenz eingesetzt
hat um die Welt Irre zu führen wir
erleben eine Lüge nach anderen und ich
möchte alle vor allen Ding in den
westlichen Ländern aufrufen erinnern
sich daran was in Irak passiert ist um
den angrffs damals zu rechtfertigen alle
haben behauptet ramsf Bus Tony Blair der
britische Premierminister dass der Irak
Massenvernichtungswaffen besäße das war
der Grund für den Angriff auf den Irak
das Ergebnis waren 1 Million Tote
Irakers nach 30 Jahr hat selbst
zugegeben dass es keine
Massenvernichtungswaffen im Irak gegeben
hat aber wer kann jetzt eine Million
Iraker wieder zurückbringen und heute
erleben wir dieselben Verbrechen dieser
schwarzen Medien die irreführende
Information verbreiten ich akzeptiere
nicht und verteidige auch nicht dass
unschuldige Zivilisten getötet werden
von Palästinensern oder auch anderen
aber hier zu behaupten dass es
Vergewaltigung gegeben hat und Kinder
enthauptet wurde ist völlig
inakzeptabel soweit die Position aus
ramala und wir sind noch mal verbunden
mit Professor Thomas Jäger in einer
erfolgreichen Verhandlungssituation hier
im Bonner phöniix Studio konnte ich für
uns zwei letzte Fragen aushandeln
Professor Jäger die nutzen wir einmal
müssen wir beginnen wir haben so viel
über Hamas gesprochen über vertach noch
zu reden die für viele durchaus auch
eine eingeführte Größe ist aber wir
müssten vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
das binenverhältnis abklären damit man
weiß wie man künftig daran denken muss
die Ver ist so eine Gegenpartei zu Hamas
und das ist die Partei wenn ich das so
grob sagen darf die als diejenige
gesehen wird die ein bisschen altbacken
ist die die Interessen der Palästinenser
nicht wirklich kraftvoll vertritt und in
der Konkurrenz zwischen beiden die ja
schon weit zurückreicht hat sich eben
Hamas durchgesetzt als die Partei die
kraftvoll gegen Israel kämpft und die
der Palästinenser vertritt das ist im
bindenverhältnis die Wahrnehmung und zur
vertach gehört Mahmut Abbas der
Präsident der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde also derjenige der
eigentlich auch im Gaza das sagen hätte
sollen aber das hat er nicht
und die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde ist eben momentan nicht
in der Lage eine konstruktive Rolle bei
der Lösung dieser jetzt entstandenen
Situation zu spielen
und das bringt uns im Grunde genommen zu
Abschluss zur 100.000 Frage wenn man es
mal in dieser Währung die als eine der
stabilsten der Welt geht noch einmal
formulieren wie geht man weiter von
diesem Tag nach einem möglichen
militärischen Auseinandersetzung also
das was wir schon mal gesagt haben das
reißbritt haben wir ausgeschlossen also
müssen wir mit Einrechnung von
gesellschaftlichen Entwicklungen nach
vorn denken mit welchen
Playern ja man muss jetzt sehen wie sich
Israel in dieser Situation entscheidet
wo ganz viel unterschiedliche Interessen
auf die israelische Regierung momentan
einwirken und wie sie die Boden
Operationen umsetzt wie lange die
Bombardierungen bleiben wie die Lage in
Gaza geregelt werden kann wie die
Entwicklungen im Informationsraum sind
und dann wird die Frage sein ob es
ausreichend Konsens zwischen Regierungen
gibt sich für eine politische Lösung
einzusetzen aber da sehe ich eben den
Widerspruch zwischen Iran an und
Saudi-Arabien als die zentrale
Kraft die genau das verhindern wird
diese beiden Staaten werden in kein
herzliches Verhältnis miteinander kommen
und das würde dann eben dazu führen dass
die Lage so bleibt wie sie ist siert
ruhiggestellt und mehr kann man im
Moment möglicherweise gar nicht machen
ein kalter Frieden dann im Nahen Osten
das wäre eine mögliche Option Professor
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler
Universität Köln wie immer ein großer
Mehrwert ein großes Vergnügen mit ihnen
zu sprechen danke für Ihre Zeit heute
für phöniix ganz herzlichen Dank Ihnen
Frau
Arland meine Damen und Herren wir gehen
noch mal einen Schritt weiter wir haben
viel gesprochen über militärische Fragen
über geopolitische fragen wir müssen und
wollen auch noch über humanitäre Fragen
etwas ausführlicher reden aber vorher
auch die entsprechenden Bilder zeigen
Krankenhäuser überfüllt das wasserknapp
die Infrastruktur am Limit die
humanitäre Situation Gaza ist mehr als
präär eine kurze Beschreibung der
Verhältnisse vor Ort
überlebenswichtiges wird knapp im
gaserstreifen Trinkwasser z.B wo es Brot
gibt bilden sich lange Schlangen Strom
für Handys liefern nur noch Solaranlagen
oder
Generatoren wir werden zurück in die
Steinzeit geworfen kein Strom kein
Wasser oder Internet kein Treibstoff
sogar Stromgeneratoren werden deswegen
langsam Sinn
die humanitäre Lage im dicht besiedelten
Gazastreifen wird immer kritischer nach
dem Überfall der Hamas vor einer Woche
hat Israel die Versorgung mit Wasser und
Elektrizität eingestellt seither greift
die israelische Armee Ziele im
Gazastreifen an vieler Orts ein Bild der
Verwüstung erneut hat die israelische
Armee die Zivilbevölkerung aufgerufen
den nördlichen Teil des gaserstreifens
zu verlassen wer sich dazu entscheidet
zu bleiben bringt sich selbst und seine
Familie in Gefahr und dient den
Interessen der Terroristen der Hamas
verlasst Gaza Stadt geht in den Süden
wir werden unsere Angriffe intensiv
fortsetzen mehr als eine Million
Menschen soll sich in Sicherheit bringen
hunderttausende sind dem Aufruf gefolgt
und nun obdachlos nach Süden ins
Nachbarland Ägypten können sie nicht
denn die Grenze bleibt für Palästinenser
geschlossen im Norden von Gaza wiederum
gilt eine baldtige Bodenoffensive als
wahrscheinlich die israelische Armee
bringt weiter panzerin Stellung soweit
also die Bilder von vor Ort mehr als
halbes mehr als ein halbes Jahrhundert
meine Damen und Herren arbeitet medico
international vorher unter dem anderen
Begriff medico allein auf dem Gebiet der
Menschenrechte mit dem Sitz in Frankfurt
am Main und in Berlin kann ich jetzt mit
Riad Osmann sprechen er ist na
ostreferent der Hilfsorganisation medico
international seit 2016 war aber vorher
Büroleiter in der Region grüße sie in
die Hauptstadt Herr
Osmann guten Tag lassen Sie uns sprechen
über das was sie hören aus der Region
sie sind ja nach wie vor vertreten haben
ihre Kontaktpersonen dort welche
Berichte erhalten
Sie also die Situation in Gaza ist
mittlerweile absolut verzweifelt wie
gerade in den Beitrag zu hören weil das
Wasser ist nicht nur knapp das Wasser
ist in den meisten Einrichtungen
tatsächlich alle also die Menschen vor
Ort haben angefangen auf nichtsichere
Wasserquellen zurückzugreifen das heißt
das Risiko steigt von äh übertragbaren
Krankheiten also Durchfallerkrankungen
oder auch Epidemien wie Typhus und
Cholera und was jetzt speziell unsere
Partner sagen mit denen ich regelmäßig
in Kontakt bin also zuletzt heute morgen
das ist dass sie ähm das das ist ein
lebendig gewordener Albtraum also wenn
Sie sich vorstellen ähm dass einer
unserer Partner zurückgeht in sein Haus
er will zurückgehen um noch Dokumente
oder Fotoalben Wertgegenstände zu
holen dann sind Teile der Stadt in Gaza
so zerstört dass er nach seinem Haus
suchen muss also es er kann sich nicht
mehr orientieren weil bestimmte Gebäude
nicht mehr da sind die früher zur
Orientierung gedient haben und das
andere ist dass die Menschen immer mehr
verstummen wurde ja auch in dem Beitrag
genannt der Strom ist abgeschaltet und
das heißt die können nicht mehr
kommunizieren oder nur noch sehr sparsam
gleichzeitig gibt es die Aufforderung
der israelischen Armee seit Freitag den
Norden des Gazastreifens Richtung Süden
zu
verlassen es gibt auch wiederum Berichte
da gibt es immer Schwierigkeiten mit der
Bestätigung dafür dass Hamas diese
Flucht der Bevölkerung zum Teil
behindert oder verhindert haben sie
dafür Belege auch
erhalten ich habe dafür selbst keine
Belege erhalten ich habe diese die
Aussagen gesehen dass Leute das sagen
ich kann dazu nicht sagen ich weiß nicht
ob das richtig ist ob das falsch ist ähm
die Leute die evakuiert haben also
unsere Partner haben eigentlich fast
alle sind sie in den Süden jenseits
dieser Linie wadiraza gegangen
die haben jetzt nicht gesagt dass sie da
irgendwie behindert wurden aber wie
gesagt das ist keine Garantie dass das
nicht stattgefunden hat für alle die
jetzt dort bleiben wollen oder müssen
z.B die Krankenhäuser haben sich ja
geweigert eine Evakuierung durchzuführen
äh was ist notwendig und was kommt
eigentlich auf welchen Kanälen was
können Sie überblicken überhaupt noch
durch für die die jetzt dringend Hilfe
vor Ort
benötigen also ich muss was zu den
Krankenhäusern sagen der Befehl das
Krankenhäuser evakuieren müssen ist ja
an sich kein legaler Befehl also
Gesundheitseinrichtung unterstehen im
internationalen Recht auch im
Kriegsrecht einen besonderen Schutz und
auch die
Evakuierung von über einer Million
Menschen die angeordnet wurde bedeutet
nicht dass deren Schutz oder deren Recht
auf Schutz im bewaffneten Konflikt
aufgehoben ist also die israelische
Armee kann die Leute fünfmal warnen und
wenn sie im Norden des Gazastreifens
Zivilbevölkerung
antrifft hat die genießt diese
Bevölkerung immer noch den gleichen
Schutz als hätte die israelische Armee
Sie nicht gewarnt und da ist es denke
ich angebracht darauf hinzuweisen oder
darauf hinzuarbeiten dass ich
der Staat Israel auch in diesem Konflikt
und auch nach diesen Verbrechen der
Hamas trotz dem man internationales
Recht halten muss das heißt die
Abriegelung wie wir sie jetzt sehen auch
die davor die schon 16 Jahre angedauert
hat 2007 war schon immer
völkerrechtswidrig und die Vorenthaltung
jetzt von
überlebensnotwendigen
Lebensmitteln Wasser Strom Elektrizität
all das stellt schon jetzt ein
Kriegsverbrechen dar ja wir nehmen Ihre
Position auf und bedanken uns für Ihre
Zeit das war riat Ossmann naustreferent
von medico international danke nach
Berlin und Grüße merci ich danke
Ihnen meine Damen und Herren wir
sprechen heute viel aber wir wollen auch
bei phöniix die Gesprächskanäle in alle
Richtungen offen halten Brüssel ist ein
wichtiger Standort heute aus zwei
wichtigen Themen heraus a der nahosten
darüber sprechen wir direkt und später
auch über eine europäische
möglicherweise Richtungsentscheidung ich
freue mich dass sich Zeit für uns nimmt
und zugeschaltet ist ZDF Korrespondent
Gunar Krüger herr Krüger grüße erstmal
in das Herzen von
Europa hallo hallo Herr Grüger reden wir
zunächst über Diplomatie da knüpfen wir
am nahen Osten tatsächlich an die
Europäische Union hat ja einen
außenbeauftragten Herr Borell aber er
ist nicht vor Ort wir fragen uns in den
letzten Tagen welche Rolle spielt Europa
bei diesen ganzen diplomatischen
Bemühungen ja die EU hat sich ja selbst
sozusagen die vor Vorgabe gegeben ein
souveränes Europa zu sein also auch auf
der Weltbühne mit zu spielen als
außenpolitischer Partner wahrgenommen zu
werden dafür steht eigentlich der
Spanier Joseph Borell Borel ist
natürlich der der die Außenpolitik nach
außen vertreten soll der eben
zusammenführen soll was die
Mitgliedstaaten bei aktuellen
außenpolitischen Themen denken und er
tut das auch man muss allerdings sagen
er ist nicht vor Ort aus gutem Grund
weil er gerade auf Chin Reise ist und
aus China oder aus seiner Asienreise
heraus hat er verschiedene Tweets abges
verschiedene Äußerung gegeben die sich
äh in der Tonwahl doch ein bisschen von
dem unterscheiden was man auf der
anderen Seite der Straße sozusagen hier
in Brüssel hören kann das ist nämlich
die EU-Kommission und dem Unterschied zu
Borell war die Chefin die Präsidentin
der EU-Kommission Ursula von derlein
tatsächlich am Freitag in Israel und
zusammen mit der Parlamentspräsidentin
metzula und sie hat dort einen anderen
Ton angeschlagen und jetzt ist dann noch
die Frage ob das ganze nur ein
kommunikatives ähm kleine kommunikative
Unterschiede sind oder ob es da
tatsächlich Inhalte dahinter steckenm
bleibt also spannend dieses
nachzubereiten in Brüssel sie werden das
weiter intensiv beobachten zweiter Punkt
noch Hilfsgelder das ist etwas was nicht
nur in den einzelen Nationalstaaten ein
bisschen Aufregung verursacht sondern
natürlich auch bei den Europäern eine
dreistellige Millionensumme die fließt
nach Palästina wie stellt Europa
eigentlich sicher dass das in die
richtigen Hände
gerät die EU hat die hamasia schon seit
2007 als Terrororganisation eingestuft
und seitdem wird alles getan um zu
versuchen dass dieses Geld tatsächlich
auch an die
Hilfsbedürftigen fließt also eben nicht
an die Terrororganisation Hamas äh da
gibt es harte Kontrollen da gab es immer
mal auch wieder Schwierigkeiten wenn z.B
ähm äh Bildung im Bildungsbereich wenn
dort Schulbücher ein bestimmtes Israel
Bild vermittelt haben also da gab es
auch Skandale aber grundsätzlich ist es
hat man sehr darauf geachtet dass das
Geld nicht in die falschen Hände fließt
aber ein Europaabgeordneter sagte uns
hier auch schon natürlich wenn man einen
stat zum guten Teil finanziert dann
bietet das immer Gelegenheit um Geld
abzuzweigen nun ist es so dass man genau
unterscheiden muss zwischen
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
humanitärer Hilfe gerade im Bereich der
humanitären Hilfe hat die EU
jetzt am Wochenende noch mal aufgestockt
die Mittel verdreifacht von 25 auf
75 Millionen Euro und vieles von dem was
ich jetzt an dem Grenzübergang zu
Ägypten staut in vielen LKW wo un drauf
steht dass vieles davon ist von der EU
finanziert also man muss ganz genau
hinschauen und wenn man noch mal in
diese Woche zurückschaut dann gab es
auch viel Verwirrung darüber ob jetzt
alle Hilfszahlung eingestellt werden
sollte und gerade wenn man nicht diese
Unterscheidung trifft zwischen
entwicklungszusammen Arbeit und
humanitärer Hilfe dann kommt man in
Gefahr dass man da unterschiedliche
Auffassungen in der Kommission entdeken
könnte dem sah aus Sicht der Kommission
dem war nicht so danke dass Sie diesen
Akzent gemacht haben Gunar Krüger für
diese erste Runde wir sprechen gleich
noch mal zum Stichwort Polen weiter
meine Damen und Herren also das bringt
uns zu einem der großen Staaten in
Europa heute eine Richtungsentscheidung
in Polen ein paar Bilder vom Wahlprozess
haben wir schon vorbereitet und eines
können wir sagen
das ist
nicht ganz einfach ja die Bilder spielen
wir noch kurz zu haben wir die noch
einfach reinhauen genau super also
größte Konkurrenten
sind die und kontrohenten sind die peace
und einen der Vertreter sehen wir hier
den Ministerpräsidenten und die
liberalkonservative
bürgerkoalition die von ihm angeführt
wird vom ehemaligen Ratspräsidenten Tusk
das bringt uns quasi auf die Gemengelage
und es bleibt spannend weil die Frage
ist wer holt hier absolute Mehrheiten
deswegen freue ich mich besonders dass
sich Zeit für uns nimmt die die AD
Korrespondentin in Warschau Christin
Joachim Frau Joachim nichts hält ewig
auch keine absoluten Mehrheiten die
Frage also wie ist die Ausgangslage an
diesem
Wahltag die Ausgangslage ist folgende
dass die regierende konservative peace
parartei seit 8 Jahren hier dieses Land
in Polen regiert und in diesen 8 Jahren
hat die peace das Land grundlegend
umgebaut sie hat unter anderem die die
Medien zu einem großen Teil unter ihre
Kontrolle gebracht vor allem em den
öffentlichrechtlichen Rundfunk das
Fernsehen das Radio
quasi zu ihrem propagandaorgan umgebaut
das hat sich natürlich vor allem jetzt
im Wahlkampf für die peace sehr nützlich
als sehr nützlich erwiesen sie hat
die Frauenrechte extrem eingeschränkt
Stichwort Abtreibungsverbot das hat sie
soweit eingeschränkt und noch in so
seltenen Fällen erlaubt dass es
tatsächlich in den letzten Jahren auch
zu fällen kam wo Frauen eine Abtreibung
verwehrt wurde
weil Ärzte Angst hatten sie
durchzuführen obwohl sie damit das das
Leben der Frau gerettet hätten und sie
hat und das ist wahrscheinlich der
einschneidendste die einschneidendste
Maßnahme gewesen zumindest was dieses
Verhältnis mit der EU angeht das
Justizsystem so umgebaut dass es von
Experten als nicht mehr unabhängig
eingeschätzt wird sie hat damit mehrfach
gegen EU-Recht verstoßen und für sich
und durch ihr verfassungsgerecht Gericht
schlussendlich auch geurteilt dass
EU-Recht für so für Polen nicht über
allem steht sondern dass die polnische
Verfassung über EU-Recht steht und damit
hat Polen hat die peace Polen immer
weiter von der EU entfernt ähm das ist
letztendlich die Ausgangslage die
aktuellen Zahlen die die aktuellen
Umfragen jetzt vor der Wahl haben die
peace mit diesem Kurs bei 35 bis
38% gesehen das ist eine niedrigere
Zustimmung als noch vor 4 Jahren da
hatte die peace nach der Wahl 43% der
Stimmen bekommen ähm das ist also die
Ausgangslage und es geht heute an diesem
Wahltag darum ob dieser Kurs der peace
weitergeführt wird oder nicht das was
sie gesellschaftlich gerade beschrieben
haben Frau Joachim
was bedeutete das für den Wahlkampf man
hat von außen den Eindruck gehabt da
gibt es keine Samthandschuhe was ist
konkret
gelaufen genau also der der Wahlkampf
wird hier ähm im Land als einer der
schmutzigsten und unfairsten oder man
kann eigentlich sagen der schmutzigste
und unfährste Wahlkampf seit
1989 beschrieben das liegt unter anderem
daran dass äh die peace ihre Macht über
die öffentlichrechtlichen Medien extrem
ausgenutzt hat wo in den
Abendnachrichten vor allem Jubelarien
auf die peace und auf ihre Politik
abgefeiert wurde und die
Opposition insbesondere Donald Tusk
eigentlich jeden Abend diskreditiert
wirurd als als Handlanger Deutschlands
als Handlanger Brüssels dargestellt
wurde der der der Polen letztendlich
seine Souveränität berauben will würde
wenn er dann Regierungschef würde ähm
die peace hat außerdem äh sehr mit sehr
vielen Tricks äh es geschafft ihr
Wahlkampfbudget enorm aufzubessern indem
sie ja auch jetzt heute ein Referendum
parallel zu den Wahlen abhält und in
diesem Referendum werden ausschließlich
Themen behandelt die den peaceewahlkampf
Nutzen da geht es vor allem um das Thema
Migration um das Thema Sicherheit und
damit konnte die peace Wahlkampfgelder
oder Gelder aus öffentlichen Mitteln für
ihren eigenen Wahlkampf nutzen und ähm
die ihren Wahlkampf hier sogar noch bis
in die Wahlkabine tragen und natürlich
war auch die Rhetorik extrem scharf
ähm das äh war teilweise unter der
Gürtellinie da hat sich dann allerdings
auch die die Opposition teilweise
angepasst also fair war das nicht und
schmutzig kann man es schon bezeichnen
ganz herzlichen Dank ob diese
Beschreibung auch der beiden Lager und
dessen was gelaufen ist für eine
Wechselstimmung dann reicht wird sich
heute Abend beantworten für ihre Zeit
herzlichen Dank im ad Korrespondentin in
Warschau ich grüße sie danke
schön wir gehen noch mal zurück nach
Brüssel denn eines kann man sagen gun
Krüger ist uns weiterhin zugeschaltet
ZDF Korrespondent dort eines kann man
sagen Polen war eigentlich noch nie ein
einfacher Kandidat für Brüssel daran
Stimmen auf jeden Fall überberein gerade
gab es beim Gipfel von Granada noch
einmal ein Veto das bezog sich auf die
Migrationsfrage welche Hoffnung gibt's
denn in Brüssel mit Blick auf
Warschau also es gibt ganz deutlich die
Hoffnung dass es weniger blockad gibt
das gründet sich äh auf zwei Annahmen
erstens dass eben diese Wahl nun heute
vorbei sein wird und dass dann beideer
Seiten sich wieder mit der EU an einen
Tisch setzen müssen äh und dass dann
eben auch kein Wahlkampfgetöse mehr äh
zu hören sein wird sondern dass man dann
eben wieder auch vernünftig miteinander
reden kann so zumindest die Hoffnung
hier in Brüssel und die andere
der andere Grund warum diese Vernunft
wieder einkehren sollte die der gründet
sich einfach auf dem Geld
insgesamt sind gut 100 Milliarden Euro
derzeit eingefroren eben wegen der eben
von Christin ja angesprochenen
Justiz Umbauten die die peace
vorgenommen hat deswegen wird die EU hat
die EU bislang 100 Milliarden Euro
zurückgehalten und jeder der jetzt in
Warschau an die Regierung kommt der wird
vor allem eins im Sinn haben wieder die
Wirtschaft
zum Laufen zu bringen und dafür sind
natürlich 100 Milliarden Investitionen
aus Brüssel mehr als wir kommen und
natürlich mischt sich hier in Brüssel
niemand in die polnische Politik ein das
grundsätzlich nicht weil sich das der
Kommission aus Sicht der Kommission
nicht gehört in den Mitgliedstaaten
reinzureden aber in diesem Fall noch mal
besonders man kann wahrscheinlich davon
ausgehen dass ganz viele Leute hier
einem Kandidaten nämlich Donald Donald
Tusk die Daumen drücken werden aber sie
lassen ihre Hände noch in der
Hosentasche der quasi eine europäische
Vita hat vielleicht noch eine
abschließende Einschätzung herr Krüger
ähm sie haben das ein bisschen
beschrieben was quasi auch zum Teil
jetzt auch ansteht wo auch
vetöglichkeiten sind aber noch mal
konkret gefragt es sind alles Profis und
Pragmatiker in Brüssel trotz der
Hosentasche was würde sich im
europäischen Gefüge faktisch ändern wenn
peace jetzt die Mehrheit
verliert das würde natürlich schon diese
diese sperminorität die Polen mit Ungarn
aufbauen konnte
in manchen Fällen aufgebaut hat auch
würde das natürlich erschweren also wenn
man davon ausgehen würde dass Donald
Tusk eine eine proeuropäische Politik
fahren würde dann könnte man von weniger
Blockaden ausgehen aber man muss auch
hier ganz genau hinschauen denn es gibt
ja auch in der EU ganz verschiedene
Themenbereiche die verschiedene
Mehrheiten für erfordern also in der
Außenpolitik in Haushaltsfragen da
braucht man
die die Einstimmigkeit in anderen Fragen
eben auch in der Migration braucht man
nur qualifizierte Mehrheiten und da hat
man von vorneerein ja Polen nicht
eingepreist wo man Polen auf auf jeden
Fall braucht das sind die ukrainehilfen
wenn man die verstätigen will
so der Vorschlag von Joseph Borel ist in
den nächsten 5 Jahren 20 Milliarden Euro
dafür extra freizuhalten wenn man dafür
bräuchte man Polen allerdings ist genau
dieses Druckmittel in Polen natürlich
nicht besonders
beliebt also Polen unterstützt die
Ukraine dabei bleibt es also Polen wenn
Polen ausgerechnet dort die EU
blockieren wollte also wenn z.B die
amtierende polnische Regierung dort Bl
ieren wollte dann wäre das ein denkbar
schlechtes Druckmittel Armdrücken ist
also in Zukunft auch nicht
ausgeschlossen ganz herzlichen Dank für
diese Einschätzung Information
Hintergründe das war Guna Krüger ZDF
Korrespondent zugeschaltet aus Brüssel
ich danke
Ihnen meine Damen und Herren wir haben
versucht 60 Minuten lang für Sie das
aktuelle zu dieser Mittagsstunde
zusammenzuholen ich darf noch darauf
hinweisen dass wir das Stichwort Polen
heute Abend noch etwas breiter spielen
dann nämlich wenn wir auf die Wahlen den
Mö ichen Wahlausgang zumindestens auf
sozusagen die Hochrechnungen und die
bisher ausgezählten Stimmen schauen das
tun wir das erste mal um 19:30 und dann
noch mit einer Spätausgabe und da
natürlich schauen wir auch was die
Entwicklungen im Nahen Osten
weiterbringen das sollte heute mittag
mal von uns das ganze Bild sein in
phöniix vor Ort für Interesse danken wir
herzlich geben sie zurück in das
Programm von Dokumentationen dass sie
sich ein wenig zurücklehnen können und
sagen gute Information bei phöniix im
Namen des
Teams
[Musik]
هها